a volley of rockets on the Libyan
capital in the dead of night it caused
mayhem
in the crowded narrow streets of Tripoli
and fresh anger for the former Gaddafi
general being blamed and who insists
he's attacking terrorists inside the
city you are here have you seen anybody
with his gun there is nothing here there
were several attacks on different areas
of the city the worst so far since the
start of Khalifa Hector's assault on
Tripoli this is obviously a residential
area
number of cars have been hit a number of
homes have been hit and they believe
that there are casualties and this is
what the prime minister of Libya is
going on about hitting residents in the
middle of the night he believes it is
unacceptable and has to stop they
crowded into the hospitals after a call
went out to give blood all this as the
United Nations continued to discuss
exactly what to do
you
outside Libya and this is a criminal and
he's crazy man
it is unbelievable you cannot believe
that one he killed his people like this
he shilling Tripoli would would grab and
you know that Hillary is a lot of
population here more than three million
this is crazy man
more than Heather there's dithering on
the international stage over this
conflict with divisions inside and
outside the UN over which side to back
and Libyan civilians are suffering alex
corset Sky News Tripoli